[Music]
russian military archives have revealed
previously unpublished documents that
challenge
well-established narratives about world
war ii
we know that from 1941 to 1945 the
western allies and the soviet union were
fighting nazis side by side
and this is how this went down in
history but according to the newly
unveiled files
that anti-hitler coalition was not
initially in the cards
in fact france and britain had planning
to attack the soviet union
before it was attacked by germany
well this is quite interesting so this
is a copy
of a note by maurice gamelin
the commander-in-chief of the french
armed forces at the beginning of world
war ii
and it outlines how the allies wanted to
strike southern caucuses
in uh what is day is urbajo this former
soviet region
still has vast oil resources and played
a significant role
in country's ability to wage war the
date
on the document suggests that uh the
french military
had such plans in february of 1940
three months before hitler invades
france and
a little over a year before he takes on
the ussr
the note was discovered by the soviets
in postwar germany along with other
documents that nazis themselves had
captured in occupied france
it says that the french military command
considered not just bombing soviet oil
fields
but also inciting muslims living in the
region to revolt against moscow
we were allies in world war ii weren't
we how did all that come to be
before we became allies a lot had
happened in europe
a lot of rather controversial things
when each country
pursued its own goals this is a photo
taken around the time that allied powers
plan to launch an attack on the soviet
union
it shows british military pilots
boarding an airplane in syria from where
airstrikes were supposed to have been
carried out
and according to this cable signed by
the head of the soviet nkvd lavrenti
beria
moscow was well aware of the buildup in
the middle east
the french intelligence service actively
seeking detailed information
regarding the topography of the area
condition of the roads
and natural obstacles in georgia armenia
and azerbaijan french intelligence is
particularly interested in
intelligence on regions that border iran
what does it mean did they plan a ground
invasion of the ussr's caucuses from
iran too
iran and turkey to help them the only
reason these plans were in put into
action says archive director vladimir
terasev
was that hitler invaded france and the
allies all of a sudden
had a more urgent problem on their hands
in 1939 joachim von ribentrop nazi
germany's foreign minister arrived in
moscow to sign a controversial
non-aggression pact with the soviet
union
his plane landed at what used to be a
major airport of the soviet capital back
then and now they
turned the place into a park because of
that pact
that brought stalin and hitler somewhat
closer for a short period
of time france and the uk started to
deem the ussr as their potential enemy
and they've been considered waging war
on the country well not everyone knows
though that before
striking a deal with berlin moscow was
actively seeking
a military alliance with london and
paris
but those suggestions fell on deaf ears
this is a declassified proposal to
britain and france by the soviet union
it's dated april 17th 1939
four months before the molotov ribbon
trap accord between the soviet union and
nazi germany
came into being
britain france and the ussr signing an
agreement for five to ten years
pledging themselves to immediately
assist each other by any means necessary
including militarily in the event of
aggression in europe against any of the
parties to that agreement
if britain france and the soviet union
had signed the proposal at the time
a full-fledged anti-hitler coalition
would have been formed
much earlier but animosity was running
high
she could give me francine leadership
were in no haste to change their policy
towards the ussr
of course they were wary of the soviet
union its social and political system
naturally their goal was to divert the
german military machine towards the east
and direct it against the soviet union
the fact is
neither britain nor france wanted to be
the first to go to war with hitler
in 1938 trying to at least postpone the
large-scale conflict
the allies even held the infamous munich
conference which allowed nazi germany to
occupy czechoslovakia
in exchange neville chamberlain
britain's prime minister at the time
brought back home a non-aggression pact
between britain and germany
a document similar to one signed between
germany and the ussr
a year later chamberlain proudly
brandished the pact
which bore hitler's signature as
symbolic of the desire of our two
peoples
never to go to war with one another
again
[Applause]
the modern historians like to point out
that hitler and stalin had struck a deal
and therefore the soviet leader was in
their opinion
equally responsible for starting the war
however
moscow was not the first power to
negotiate with berlin
in the late 1930s
is a story people like to pick and
choose historical facts that they like
and nobody wants to talk about
uncomfortable things
britain and france's desire to appease
germany on one hand
and their reluctance to negotiate with
the ussr and the other
led moscow's leadership into believing
that the ussr could be hitler's next
target that's when joseph stalin and his
closed inner circle locked themselves
inside his country residents
with the map of europe i guess this is
one of the most important exhibits at
your museum
you should probably be careful with it
it will be one of the most
interesting things at the exhibition a
map of europe from the 1930s containing
notes by stalin is on public display for
the first time
it shows the soviet leader's vision of
what the ussr
security zone should look like
so everything that's colored blue and
red is this is stalin
did he write it himself yes absolutely
this
here using a red pencil he marked
central europe mitel europa
as they called it so basically it was
germany's fear of interest
but it's not just germany it's also
austria czechoslovakia
at that point germany had already
absorbed czechoslovakia
the soviet security zone included
territories that had been part of the
russian empire for centuries
and were recently lost during the
bolshevik revolution and civil war
these were the baltic states western
belarus and ukraine controlled by poland
the region of bessarabia controlled by
romania
and the region of corellia close to the
city of leningrad
some historians will look at this map
and say here's how stalin and hitler
plan to divide europe
therefore they are to blame for world
war ii
stalin was no shrinking violet
he was concerned about the geopolitical
situation near the ussr's borders
and he wanted these regions secure as
the russian historians claim
the soviet leadership didn't want to
incorporate the baltic states initially
but had to change their mind when they
saw growing sympathy between political
elites in those countries
and nazi germany a soviet secret agent
in lithuania sent
this cable to moscow after clandestinely
attending a meeting where one of the
members of a local nationalistic party
was reading an unofficial message from
german's foreign ministry
germany wants to change the system in
the baltic states and turn them into the
united states
where lithuania would be the main player
due to its geographical closeness to
germany
and good relations between the two
countries before long
in the summer of 1940 lithuania and the
two other baltic states had become part
of the soviet union
so we're gonna need white gloves to work
with these documents yes
these are unique documents
[Music]
this is an original declaration from
1940 where the recently installed
lithuanian government
formally asks for the republic to be
accepted into the soviet union
similar documents were submitted by
latvia and estonia and became
legal grounds for their inclusion
current officials in those nations
denounced it as an occupation
but back then it was internationally
recognized and saw
no objections either from berlin or from
london in paris
why did moscow need these three baltic
states as part of the soviet union
first and foremost for the security of
the country so it can stand against
germany's potential aggression
if there had been no soviet troops the
german army would have been standing
there
would it have been good for the baltic
countries or not well
that certainly would not have been good
for the soviet union
while in the baltic states the soviets
received a lukewarm welcome
in western belarus and ukraine which
poland had captured from russia just two
decades before
local population were much more
enthusiastic
[Music]
we have a lot of evidence we have photos
and video footage that show that the
locals welcomed the red army as
liberators how much of it is just soviet
propaganda
you see historically poland never had
some of the lands it had then
it got them as a result of the polish
soviet war these territories were ceded
to poland
in accordance with the peace of riga the
locals ukrainians and belarusians didn't
do well out of that
as the red army took control of western
belarus in ukraine
and the german military seized western
polish provinces
poland lost its sovereignty in response
to the germans aggression
britain and france which had guaranteed
poland's independence
finally declared war in hitler but did
little to actually help their embattled
ally
there are captured photographs in
russia's archives showing british and
french soldiers hanging out in paris
cafes
and playing football in the rear at the
same time as nazi troops were invading
poland this was later called the phony
war
[Music]
it became clear that poland was
disintegrated and the polish army was
only half capable
it was surrounded the germans were
laying siege to warsaw
and in 24 hours it would be over for
poland
at a military council the allies made
the decision to stop
all offensive operations these are real
facts
and you can make your own conclusions it
seems they didn't really want a fight
for moscow this became yet another
signal that the allies couldn't be
trusted
and that the soviet union should further
secure its western front before a
looming war with nazi germany but unlike
in poland and the baltics
in finland moscow faced stubborn
resistance
the finns refused to move their border
away from leningrad
russia's second largest city this
resulted in a soviet finnish war
in late 1939
this is the map that had been drawn by
the red army general staff upon
agreement with the finnish side
here is the signature of marshall
shropshnikov dated october 12
1939 another authentic map from that
period which is appearing on public
display for the first time
shows soviet proposals for swapping
territories with finland
moscow had been ready to give a large
chunk of its land in exchange for a
buffer in front of its second capital
and therefore settle the issue without
going to an unnecessary war with its
north
western neighbor
they showed attitude later in post-war
finland a committee was formed to review
those issues
and its conclusion was that they should
have agreed as a result of the following
war with the ussr
finland lost much more territory than
moscow had initially asked for
of course the soviet finnish conflict
the division of poland and its betrayal
by the allies
the appeasement policy and the secret
talks with nazi germany
none of this looks good for any country
in the run-up to the war
this was a tough time there were hardly
any good choices available
and thanks to these archived documents
we can still separate the truth
from the misconceptions